probably starting this video out by
giving love to the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by display
offers high quality prints on metal with
a ton of options available movies video
games comic books comic book movies and
bring those examples up because I talk
about movies video games comic book
movies here they also have an impressive
collection of nature life art astronomy
hanging the prince on the wall really
simple just wipe down the Walls stick
the magnet to the wall the print sticks
to the magnet and if you hang a proper
Halloween print in Your sponsorship
segment you're like it's November now
changing out any prints as easy as one
two done simple as changing out a magnet
on a fridge so click the link in the
description get yourself a special
discount 32 off of one or two prints or
38 off of three or more prints that is
for a limited time though so act fast
thank you once again to display it for
sponsoring this video I do appreciate it
and now let's talk about a movie which
is the epitome of the phrase I'm not
crying you're crying
[Music]
so black panther wakanda forever is the
newest film in the MCU the sequel to
Black Panther and is a film that took on
a seemingly impossible task in which the
real-life tragic passing of Chadwick
Boseman has worked into the script of
this movie in which King t'challa has
passed and while this tragedy has
befallen wakanda a new character named
Neymar or no more I know internet's like
his name is Neymar they call him no more
in the movie but in the movie some
people call him Neymar some call him no
more I appreciate people like me who'd
suck with names there's no way we can
mispronounce it that's nice but he's
from a super secret underwater
civilization that's legally not Atlantis
though in the comic books it's Atlantis
but they can't say that point is it's a
civilization of blue people who live in
water as part of the MCU not the other
property that Disney also owns and now
they're having conflict with wakanda
emotions are high tensions are high
which before I get to what really
carried the film for me I'm going to
talk about it's basically I'm going to
treat this like a dish I'm going to
start on the outside and just work my
way in so I thought Neymar was a good
villain I say that to say that to
address it because it's an MCU villain
you know it's usually that's the caveat
where it's like yeah so weak part the
MCU villain but there's definitely a
conscious effort to make Namor part of
the plot you know make them a very big
piece of this story also early on in the
movie when the troops do the first
attack I was like oh these guys are
scary I chalked that one up to the
musical score as well the music in this
movie I thought it was great it was
exciting when it needs to be also Eerie
when it needs to be they were almost
like specters the film does a good job
but early on getting your fight or
flight senses going at the presence of
them also the performances the
performances are great all around but
you do have your standouts like Angela
Bassett couple of scenes in particular I
was like she she has never lost it we
all knew that
yeah one scene in particular it was just
it was a very emotionally
heart-wrenching monologue and when this
film has the characters give these
emotional moments because of the passing
of King t'challa it it's very clear or
rather I should say it's unclear as to
whether or not you're seeing the
character grieve or the actor grieve but
not in a way that compromised it in a
way that enhanced the experience it's
not like you're sitting there going oh I
see the actor rather than the character
but in a very real way where you feel
The Grieving through the screen but
really it sure is emotional story her
emotional Journey that is the core of
this film that's when I was most engaged
right there in fact early on in this
film there was a moment where it
establishes that
a fulcrum in here is shuri's scientific
mind and her spiritual pain
are conflicting or at the very least
there's friction among those two parts
of her and I was like I'm in this is I
think we've hit Peak MCU existential
crisis let's go and then the movie's
like yeah but we are the MCU so we'll
Circle back around to that in about two
hours it much the same way I'll Circle
back around to Leticia Wright and how
she's a complete and total Legend in
this film uh but first I mean I'd love
to say everything worked but not
everything did because as I was so
invested in this emotional Journey this
emotional quest in this film we then go
and hang out with side characters Martin
Freeman's brought into this movie again
there's another side character a new
character that's brought into it anytime
I'm hanging out with these characters
I'm like I I don't think this movie had
to be two hours 40 minutes long it's
like you can't Phantom edit them out
because they are woven into the plot but
when I'm hanging out with these
characters I was thinking a couple of
script revisions I think could have
streamlined a couple of Concepts we
could have saved ourselves some time
also as much as I like the not
atlanteans legally speaking Yeah when
they first show up like I said it was
super scary because the musical score is
really aiding in that and it was a new
civilization with a new technology
that's generally speaking new for this
world but after that when you start
getting to know the civilization I
didn't feel the film hammered home the
fact that this civilization is as
technologically Superior and threatening
as the film is telling me they're
supposed to be like wakanda's wakanda
well-established they're technologically
speaking ahead of everybody it's not
even close and this not Atlantis
civilization is supposed to feel like
they are a threat to wakanda but if
you're looking at them their Tech their
numbers you're like I think wakanda
could still kick their ass fine it's
like I woke up in a world where wakanda
just only had one aircraft ever in the
entire place but the movie said they're
a big threat so you know I guess they're
a big threat for this film so more falls
on Neymar like he's the one who is the
threat and I do also appreciate the fact
that director Ryan coogler doesn't make
this movie you know MCU comedy to the
point of a parody couple of humorous
moments yeah mostly from umbaku because
Winston Duke is a legend as well he's
just one of those dudes that on screen
can say a line it's like well now this
is your scene you did that he has that
super power mbaku isn't used as much in
this film as he was the previous film
but what he is used it is gold never
felt like I was watching an MCU comedy
slash parody I really appreciate that
but in the end all in all I thought the
film was solid I give all the props in
the world to Ryan coogler for pulling
that off the entire cast for pulling
that off and I Gotta Give special love
to Leticia Wright she stepped up to a
plate I don't think she ever really
signed on to step up to Chadwick Boseman
tragically passes then she's told she's
going from support character to
emotional focal point of the entire next
film I can't imagine the pressure of
that and she carried it she was what
made this film at its best when it was
at its best it was because we were
following her her emotional Journey her
story when I had the feels she was there
when I started getting the man tears she
was there her emotional quest in this
film is absolutely what made it for me
I'll say I had myself a great time with
this one no alcohol required all right
so black panther wakanda forever I know
it comes out in a few days I feel like
asking you have you seen it what did you
think about it it's a little you know
Hasty but after this Thursday it's a
totally applicable question so have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]